last week we had Dave Portnoy a barstool
sports on this program to discuss how
the NFL stole a slogan for a t-shirt
that he came up with at the time the NFL
was girding for a lawsuit from barstool
sports but they have thankfully back
down in the powerful face of Dave
Portnoy who joins us tonight to
celebrate his victory against the
megalith the NFL how did you do this how
did you win how'd you beat the NFL
nobody does that uh you know I don't
really know I thought I found out as of
walking out of the office I think
Thursday that they submitted I've used
the analogy we said you know either pick
up a sword and fight or roll over and
let us put your belly like a dog and
Goodell rolled over and we're petting
his belly's legs going so I don't have I
don't have the recipe but they rolled
over so it's great so basically they're
afraid of the power that you wield as
the head of barstool sports I think they
were afraid that they were just wrong I
mean they stole the shirt they said we
didn't have a trademark we did so I
don't think they expected to get called
on it we called on it and they rolled
over good for you it's nice it's it's
nice to see justice prevail once in a
while so the NFL is in a pretty tough
spot lost a ton of viewers and I think
they're worried it's fair to say so you
follow this for a living why do you
think that is what's the core problem in
the NFL well I think it's a combination
thing mostly I think there's more
competition there's so many different
ways to view different whether it be
sports entertainment channels the
internet yeah so they got to fight for
eyeballs and they're not doing a great
job with it he's kind of lost touch
Goodell has I think with just the
general people so all the factors coming
together but competition number one
places like us places they can just you
know consume content a million different
ways it's hard to keep attention spans
do you think taking position against the
the famed New England football franchise
might have hurt the NFL in the anime
when you mess with Tom Brady do you
think there
karmak reckon secuence --is to that well
what do you think of course I mean
anytime they mess with a basically a
deity you you run the risk of running
into the repercussions that's what
happened yeah so you tried to warn them
just the fact right no I mean that's
that's exactly right
do you think they regret not listening
to you
I think you raised this years ago when
you said you guys are realistic Raiders
of the Lost Ark you're pulling the tiki
off the stone you don't know what's
gonna happen and they just totally blew
you off and kept hassling him have they
apologized for ignoring your wisdom if
they have it to this to this point I
think that Roger Goodell has still
refused to admit that we exist even
though we've sued them we've gone to
jail
protesting them we've done a lot of
things but last time I checked he said
he had never heard of us so he has not
apologized formally but we await that so
I heard you got a bee sting today it was
a major bee sting Tucker I was laying at
the pool I'm in Miami and I was just
relaxing and next thing I knew I got
stung by B my finger blew up but I'm
here and it's nine o'clock on a Friday
and that just speaks to my work ethic so
almost like a mailman it doesn't matter
what nature throws at you you bull
forward yeah and the mailman I don't
know that thing continued through this I
mean again there's all sorts of I'm not
gonna you know I'm not gonna disparage
mailman oh I know I'm here I did my job
to quote Bill Belichick I'm on with you
it's nine o'clock I'm in Miami on
vacation and I'm just punching that
clock that brick by brick brick by brick
el Presidente you're a good man thanks
for joining us tonight thank you